Donald Trump's 2019 State of the Union
speech was very long and sort of
difficult to sum up but in thinking of
just the kind of most concise
all-encompassing way I could describe it
I would say it was meaningless political
platitudes and an unconscionable use of
people as political props poorly
presented during a speech that just
lasted way longer than it should have
and I went in looking to evaluate policy
ideas how much does Donald Trump lie
what accomplishments does he claim and
how was the speech as a speech aside
from my political ideology and it ended
up being more than well more than an
hour very different than Donald Trump's
previous State of the Union address I'm
going to show you a one particular clip
a little bit later but for the most part
I just want to give my thoughts because
the video itself is is widely available
in many of you side now as a speech in
and of itself it was atrocious no
momentum extremely slow an unsure
delivery oftentimes just one week
applause line after another in rapid
succession as a speech it really wasn't
good why was it so long and slow I think
part of it is just lack of command and
control by Donald Trump another part
could be deliberately doing a long
speech I mean listen Trump has
authoritarian tendencies and like many
other authoritarians he likes hearing
himself speak and there is a long
history in the 20th century of
authoritarian speaking for a really
really long time and Donald Trump of
course still within a completely normal
range of State of the Union addresses
but opting for longer than shorter and
why not eat away at the amount of prime
time that Democrats will have for their
response speech but truly too long and
no momentum whatsoever as far as the
content also one of the worst State of
the Union addresses that I can remember
in terms of the substance but maybe one
that actually did a good job for Donald
Trump's base just not for anybody else
the disgust
use of political props was particularly
shameless and there's always some use of
people in the crowd here with us in the
audience is ex everybody collapse how
inspiring USA USA and the president
looked so presidential there's always a
little bit of it but I've never seen it
this bad right at the opening I mean
usually you wait until you're halfway
through your speech right at the opening
going to a girl who had cancer no
connection at all to policy or anything
other than Trump wants to fight cancer
which who doesn't but there is something
truly horrible actually if you think
about its meaning a president who is
super rich himself is celebrating at the
State of the Union to win political
points with who I guess with his base
that a girl with cancer raised money for
cancer treatment for people who can't
afford it because that's a problem in
the United States of America in any
other developed nation we would call
this a tragedy not an inspiring story to
be celebrated and then going directly
from the girl with cancer to veterans
and to astronaut Buzz Aldrin despite
having shown no real interest in space
exploration other than establishing a
space military so just pandering and
then the most disgusting moment that
I've maybe ever seen at a State of the
Union address was when Donald Trump
talked about the synagogue shooting in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania without
mentioning that it was a right-wing
terrorist and then used World War two
veterans and Holocaust survivors as
political props Jews are being attacked
by the anti-semites and white
nationalists that Donald Trump has
coalesced and catalyzed and excited one
example is the Pittsburgh synagogue
shooting Trump mentioned the shooting
but he didn't say a word about the fact
that this was a right-wing shooter
motivated by exactly the types of ideas
that Donald Trump himself has been
providing cover for and then he mentions
hey the Holocaust was bad and here's a
survivor from the Holocaust
the audience and an American soldier who
saved him no connection to Trump's
policy no connection to Trump's ideology
quite the opposite actually
no reasonable political point that
relates to what Donald Trump is trying
to do it was the Holocaust was terrible
people survived and here's one cheer for
them cheer for me USA USA but
unfortunately it probably worked well on
Donald Trump's base even though it was
again one of the most disgusting uses of
people of victims as political props
during a State of the Union address that
I can remember unconscionable truly
unconscionable and even the looks on
some of these folks faces as Donald
Trump was using them to try to win
political capital were not exactly the
faces based on my reading that were
overjoyed with the way that Donald Trump
was working this out so the the optics
just absolutely disgusting
then we get to policy what policy calls
the Donald Trump make during the speech
he said he wants to pass the u.s. MCA
that sort of NAFTA replacement deal he
wants to pass the reciprocal trade act
which is of course completely
unnecessary we already have an
infrastructure to respond to trade moves
by other countries with our own it's
merely political posturing and throwing
red meat to his base and then of course
again the wall the wall with the same
proposal the same request the same plan
I don't even know what else there is to
say about it we've already analyzed it
after his first White House speech about
it and after his second White House
speech about it my hope would be that
Nancy Pelosi doesn't give him a single
penny for it in nine days when we come
up against another possible government
shutdown and then on North Korea Donald
Trump claimed that his actions have
averted war with nuclear Korea with
North Korea with nuclear North Korea to
to actually be totally precise Trump
said that if it weren't for him we would
probably have gone to war already with
Kim Jong Un's North Korea
which is hard to imagine given that
North Korea's rhetoric has been
unchanged for 50 years and there hasn't
been a war and then maybe the most
boneheaded moment of the night Donald
Trump actually tried to take credit for
the record number of women in Congress
even though they're mostly Democrats
running against Trump's regime not
Republican women this one I'm going to
play for you Trump touts women getting
jobs and the newly elected House
Democrats stand and Trump says thank you
takes credit for it and then continues
with this don't sit yet you know like
this and exactly one century after
Congress passed the constitutional
amendment giving women the right to vote
we also have more women serving in
Congress than at any time before
yes indeed
[Music]
and of course the iron is that of the
hundred and two women in the house
eighty-nine are democrats thirteen and
republicans and the women in congress
are there
despite from not because of him unless
you want to say that because of trump
there has been such pushback that we
have now elected on the Democratic side
a record number of women to the House of
Representatives and then lastly and this
is most ironically maybe Donald Trump
called for an end to partisan
investigations the president used the
state of a union to attempt to end a
Justice Department investigation into
possible criminality which is arguably
attempting to interfere with the Justice
Department and he also sort of primed
the pump as I was talking about with
producer max before we started today by
saying that partisan investigations are
bad for the economy setting up that if
indeed the economy and economic
indicators start to not do so well he
can start to shift blame to what he
calls partisan investigations so on
substance and tone a terrible speech on
political prop use completely
unconscionable and disgusting but to go
back to the very beginning this was
probably a pretty good speech from the
point of view of firing up Trump's base
taking accomplishment taking credit for
accomplishments real and imagined many
imagined throwing out red meat pathetic
but effective use of people in the crowd
to get people clapping and then most
importantly for his base attacking
abortion and attacking socialism and
communism for no practical reason other
than just firing up his base Trump
brought up abortion and said we have to
fight against it not the most obvious
topic in 2019 and then he also brought
up socialism and communism and said we
have to fight it like we've done in the
past and it must be defeated socialism
is not a threat there are almost no
socialists in the United States nor in
Congress we're talking about just a tiny
tiny minority I don't know of any truly
socialist policy that even has a chance
in the United States Medicare for all
isn't the socialist policy it's a policy
that you have in every capital
economy in the West that is at our level
of development and economic size our
allies around the world are all
capitalist economies and they have
medicare-for-all or something like it
so Trump's speech was promoted as
something that would unite but he
attacked socialism for no reason
he attacked abortion for no reason he
used political props disgustingly he
called for wall money every single one
of those actions is the opposite of
uniting those are not the country is
divided because of exactly the issues
that Donald Trump chose to focus on
during his State of the Union so it was
an absurd theater performance but my
guess is that trumpets absolutely ate it
up I haven't seen approval or
favorability reports polls about the
State of the Union address yet but my
guess is that the Trump is loved it and
what that gets us back to when we circle
back on that basis we can't convince
them right the way that we will win in
2020 is not by convincing trumpets that
the speech was disgusting riddled with
lies and an embarrassment in the United
States they're not going to believe it
the only way to win is by voting him out
and getting them out meaning that it's a
turnout game I've been saying it for two
years the State of the Union address
only reinforces and confirms that I want
to hear from you what did you think
about the State of the Union address I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is sponsored in part by
suppresive ox who are offering everybody
in our audience a bunch of really cool
free stuff suppressor Vox is a company
based in New York City and they are
going to make your life a lot easier
and save you money when it comes to
keeping up with men's fashion because
when you sign up for spreads about
you'll get a totally new box sent to
your door every month with five or six
hand-picked accessories and pieces of
clothing you'll get things like really
stylish socks neckties high-end
sunglasses wallets watches bracelets
high-quality pens and hair combs the
list goes on but it's all really nice
stuff must-have
any guy who's wanting to update his
wardrobe I got some really cool stuff in
my espresso box including a money clip
as well as a very nice pocket square and
some really good-looking socks all of
which are very very cool thus preserve
our subscription is just 25 bucks a
month but you definitely come out ahead
because every box every single month is
guaranteed to have items with a combined
value of over $100 so they make it easy
to keep your outfits fresh but you're
also getting a lot of bang for your buck
and it makes a really great gift for a
guy in your life everyone in our
audience can get one month totally free
when you click the link underneath this
video and use the promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n